good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
today it is my honor and privilege to
welcome our speaker dr
hong wei dong who is professor of
neurobiology at the university of
california
in los angeles dr dong received both his
md and his phd
in china after which he became a
postdoctoral fellow in the laboratory of
dr larry swanson
at the university of southern california
following his post-doctoral fellowship
he was a
founding neuroscientist at the allen
brain institute in seattle washington
where he worked to construct the
original allen reference atlas for the
brain of the c-57 black laboratory mouse
this atlas and its revisions have been
at the core of many allen brain atlas
research projects
research products papers and other
resources
dr dong began his faculty career at ucla
in 2007 in the laboratory of
neuroimaging where he pioneered several
white matter fiber tract tracing
methodologies
publishing many papers in prominent
journals in 2013 he and his laboratory
relocated across los angeles to the
university of southern california
he's recently returned to ucla's
department of neurobiology
um to take on a professorship there and
to continue this painstaking work
he's sponsored by several grants from
the national
institutes of health's brain initiative
and his research focuses on
the multi-scale wiring diagram and
cataloging the cell types
in the mouse brain most notably dr dong
is the founder and director of the mouse
connectome
project mouseconnectum.org which is a
valuable resource for understanding
the brain connectivity in the standard
laboratory mouse
as noted he has received funding through
the nih brain initiative
and at one time was listed among the top
1 of
nih-funded researchers again the work in
his laboratory includes that painstaking
work involved of track tracing studies
of neuronal fiber pathways in the brain
of the c-57 black laboratory mouse
and uses uh computational methodologies
to examine the rich patterns of neuronal
connectivity and to make inferences
about the wiring patterns
of the standard laboratory mouse brain
today his lecture is
titled um uh
hold on today his lecture is titled
assembling uh global networks of the
mouse brain
and um as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you're watching on
youtube thank you for joining us
uh also our specially selected 20 20 20
2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr dong via the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them
on your behalf in the last 10 minutes or
so of dr dong's lecture
and with that welcome hong wei we are
very very excited to hear your lecture
today
okay uh first i want to send jack
invite me to give this talk and talk
about our
work in the last 10 years and that was a
very nice introduction thank you very
much jack
all right uh so my laboratory
uh in the last 10 years as what jack
mentioned uh we're trying to map the
brain map the neural circuitry
and this project is part of the brain
initiative
and um for the one major
uh topic for the brain initiative
uh is try to understand how the
difference many neurons it's six billion
neurons that's in human
but it's uh in the mouse brain about a
hundred million
neurons how these different neurons they
connect to each other
uh form and neural networks conduct the
uh
different behavior functions you know
how the different business what's
happening when the circuitry gets
disrupted and how that will relate to
different disease models
and obviously this is not the easy task
in the mammalian brain from mouse to
human
there are about 800 to
1000 different brain structures our
mission is to try to understand
how these different brain structures
they are connected with each other
individually at regional level and
also eventually will be at a single
neuron
resolution so obviously the brain
is organized at a as a highly organized
heart heretic networks so obvious
from the first is the brain and the
brain itself can be
subdivide several major subdivisions
cerebral hemisphere
cerebellum lower brain stem and each one
of them
in turn can be subdivide multiple
structures and eventually go to the
individual brain structures and then
subdivisions and then
um individual neurons that is uh
the automated resolutions look at the
individual neuron resolution
so when we map the brain we can follow
obviously
different principles one principle is
just like our human body
you look at topographically what's
happening in the head
four limbs the lower limbs uh and in the
brain
basically you can look at the the cortex
uh basal ganglia asylums hop asylum that
is one way to look at topographically
and another way is follow their
system level just like in the human body
at the beginnings
you can look at the for example
circulation system that you got
the uh veins uh um
artery and a heart and they organize as
a network
or muscle system so in the brain also
the same thing
this uh diagram that is from
kaha's original joints you know here he
showed his
dorsal root ganglia cells sends the
process
to the skin and receive this sensory
information
get into the spinal cord and then this
information goes
up to the silence then go to the cortex
from cortex can send the
projections directly to the spinal cord
and innervate motor neurons and that
innovates the muscle so basically that
is across
multiple stations that is the whole
system
so that is one level we can understand
how these different brain structures
they organized as
networks so again i show you
these are another cohouse original
joints you can see beautifully showed
in the retina has multiple different
cell types each
individual neurons they have dendrites
receive the inputs and
axons go to the next uh
target and here's a tactile
and send the projection to here and the
neurons here also receive the impulse go
to the
its own target so it's from one station
to another one
uh so overall in the last several
decades
uh so we intern neuroscience
um is in particular for anatomy what
we're trying to understand always the
three major things
one is the different cell types in the
individual regions
and in terms of their circuitry the ones
local circuitries how the
locally uh individual neurons
they affect with each other especially
for local circuitry so we talk about the
interneurons uh they affect the
surrounding neurons and for long-range
projections we really look at their
extrinsic
connections so
if we look at the diagram like one
individual
regions they send projections to the
downstream
and also receive inputs from upstream
as a chin uh connections
uh but we should keep it in mind
uh is one individual burning regions
obviously you can
keep subdividing into the smaller
subdivisions and
in the at the regional level we look at
we use classic tracer so we can look at
the region of
connections input output but at the
final resolution each
individual regions also contains
multiple different brings
multiple cell types and this individu
these individual cell types their
connections can be really different
and uh eventually while we go to the
single neural resolution
so uh another uh
major thing what as a neuroscientist
we maps in your circuitry is uh we're
not only
uh producing the data just that is one
major thing i want to emphasize as
this is a brain initiative connect home
so our mission is not only just
producing large amount of data but a
really even more
important thing also is to
understand uh this data convert this
uh connectivity data imaging data into
the usable knowledge
uh just like a cacao originally he got
this beautiful joints here but you
notice all these little arrows here
to show you how the different part of uh
the structures they connect
with each other uh this obviously is a
classical
trace synaptic circuitry is from
internal cortex to dental gels to c3c1
uh this circuitry is that's our job as a
neuroscientist
neuroanatomy so we're not only producing
data but also
really understand how this data what's
that data means
and one important thing
is for each individual nodes in this
connections they can receive the
multiple inputs for example these nodes
and two here receives the multiple
inputs
receive the convergence inputs but also
they can send a projection downstream we
didn't put here but it's also
sent to the multiple inputs to the
multiple target just like on one here
has
one target here another target here so
which means like
when we look at map the circuitries we
start from
individual brain structures as one
functional nodes
uh see their inputs see their output but
also we need to understand from
multiple nodes how this eventually puts
together these networks how they
interact with each other
so uh overall if we look at the entire
brain
how they connect with each other it's
almost just like these pianos piano has
a
fixed number of keys but with
different combinations they can play
infinitive
music piece so our brain the automate
the the basic elements that is motor
neurons but these
different combinations they can conduct
different
behavior different functions so the
neural circuitry itself
that is for how to organize these
different
individual neurons individual brain
structures
and affords a more higher and
higher level complex cognition
emotion and behavior so overall that is
my
introduction i just talked about it like
an hour over all my programs
like uh try to understand the first
things understand how the whole brain
constructs the whole brain wiring
diagram and
uh then we try to understand each
individual brain structures there
how many different cell types and then
we need to understand
at a single neuron resolution their
input output
um organization so this mouse connectome
project as jack mentioned we started
this purge project
uh about 10 years ago when i was at ucla
uh that was a start beginning with
together with ali institute
their connection project and also cold
spring
harbor has another brain architecture
connectivity project
so this is three major projects to map
the
mouse brain miso scale connections
um so this is one of the example
images i want to show so the our
connectome project we use multiple
fluorescent tracers
can label multiple pathways at the same
time so for example
the red color fibers bundles that is
come from
a secondary motor cortex and this green
color that is from infrared limbic
critical areas
you know at the same time we also label
the neurons
that's the individual neurons they
project back to the cortex
so um
so in my talk today what i want
uh present is in our last 10 years work
we start from this map the cortex
to look at how entire cortical different
cortical areas they connect with each
other
they form these different cortical
cortical networks and then
systematically look at the entire cortex
to the striatum and then look at the
from striatum
their projections to the downstream
pattern [ __ ]
and from here project back to the xylems
and then back to the cortex
the reason for that one is because it's
an entire cortical
basal ganglia islamic circuitry that is
one of the most
functional motifs in the brain i
involved many functions
involved many diseases
so the for the code copies of ganglions
in human brain you know we know they
have the caudate putamen
here's the massive cortex and also
here's the
uh globus pallidus and here's the
[ __ ] uh this in human and in the
classical
classical view for cortical basal
ganglia system is
they form these several parallel uh
major uh major
loops called cortical basal ganglia
cellamic loop
and eventually back to the cortex
involved with different functions like a
motor
and eye movements and cognition emotion
things so in the last 10 years we did
the systematic
uh studies refined this is called the
entire cortical piece of ganglia islamic
globe
so first we look at the entire cortex
it's a
mouse neocortex this work
was published in 2014
and uh the method we used is called
double co-injection which means like
in each individual brain we
do the stereotactic surgeries make two
injections
each injections contains one retrograde
tracers
back label their upstream neurons at
same time
label their downstream projections so
once fluorogold
bda actually now we use more as av and
another injections we uh reach a great
treasure that is a
color toxin anterior tracers phl
so in this case in one brain we can map
up four parallel
uh pathways two anterior grid to
retrograde
and so here's the examples to show this
uh
control lateral side of secondary motor
cortex
axons come from the injection site and
this
retrograde labeling neurons project back
to the injection site
here's their uh samples of the
labeling neurons and
here's one example injection site you
can see the axons come from injection
site go to the contralateral side
generate axonal terminals and here's
terminals at the same time
the ritual grid neurons also here these
neurons project back to the
contralateral side and when we see this
overlapped anterior grid retrograde we
know this region and this region they
have
reciprocal connections so for the entire
mouse cortex we use the 300
injection site which means because the
remember each injection site
we have a mixed one anterior grid one
retrograde
so which means like we have totally 600
pathways
so we selected 240 pathways we generate
this
uh connectivity map
in the entire cortex use different
colors
map there uh different pathways uh
so for example like here we showed is
all this
entire somatic sensory
cortical areas primary motor secondary
motor primary sensory
secondary sensories and totally all
these
individual somatic sensory motor areas
and then
we look at their pathways and then
we find out uh this entire semantic
motor passwords they are organized as
several
parallel sub-networks for example
all this green color labeled pathways
that is in the controlled upper limb
uh movement include the primary motor
cortex
has their upper limb domain primary
somatosensory has their upper limb
domain
and secondary motor cortex have their
upper limb demands and it's a green blue
color that is for
the oral official and the red color that
is
for more lower limb so basically the
total is the three
four to four parallel different
different
uh sub networks can show different part
of a semantic sensory metal cortex
functions and also
another major networks we call it media
networks
which means uh includes the visual
cortex
auditory cortex and a resource planning
area that is received directly input
from hub
campus so basically the information from
outside the world
visual auditory and spatial information
these guys uh they they
share massive connections with richard's
planning area
until anterior cingulate cortex these
cortical areas along the midline of the
brain and then they form this high level
uh interconnect networks and then
project the
frontal cortex that is orbital frontal
cortex
and this network that is really the
process the information from outside
world
on the other hand the cortical areas
along the
lateral edge of the cortex for example
and agranular insular cortex in toronto
cortex
and temporal uh association areas
these guys form two parallel uh pathways
that connect with each other also
connect to the
mid media prefrontal cortex they process
information from our inner world that is
a visceral
olfactory gastrin and self awareness
this information so if we put together
uh conduct this kind of network
matrix analyze we find the entire cortex
they are organized
as about a dozen different sub networks
for example like a four semantic sensory
motor areas
two media sub-networks and two
lateral sub-networks they are organized
as these
functional networks conduct a different
behavior
and interesting all of these connections
they have the interactions
are run in the frontal area that
i think that is the information can
allow the entire cortex information they
flow
this uh intact through this
amount these different sub networks so
overall that is our work for maps the
entire cortical
networks so after that one our next
step was we look at how the entire
cortex
the interactive is a striatum because
the stratum that is the first
station received the inputs from the
entire cortex
and this work uh is the
to do that uh we
we made the injections into the all the
different
cortical areas and then to look at their
projection patterns
in the mouse stratum and interestingly
we we saw almost like no identical
uh labeling patterns in the striatum for
example
these injections in the primary
somatosensory cortex
their terminal field men is here you see
their terminals
like this pattern um but another way the
parietal association areas
they show this kind of a band um another
injection is in the visual cortex
this shows is a vertical band near the
lateral ventricle
so basically it's overall the from
individual cortical areas they project
to the stratum
they not only show this heterogeneous
their distribution patterns are
different but also even there are
terminals how they
distributing the striatum also is really
different
so and then we generate this detailed
map
for the axonal terminals from individual
cortical areas
put them together you can see their uh
distinguished topographic patterns
some critical areas they have more
overlap
some is relatively segregate so
basically we can see the house from
different critical areas of their
convergence and divergence in different
part of
strident and then we can conduct this
systematic quantitative analyze
for their terminals in strident so
this part i don't have time to go to the
detail but however we just really look
at
from each individual cortical areas
where they are really
dense terminal core and also they are
diffused
terminals iran because this one has a
different
functional meanings for the inputs to
innovate
the different stratum part and
then we look at a topographically how
different part of a stratum
their terminals correlate with a
different part of a stratum for example
the green color that's a uh metal
somatic sensory motor areas involved
uh this uh lower limb trunk and
actually the upper limb uh artificial
part the projections mainly go to this
ventral lateral side of the striatum
this part mostly is involved or official
this artificial
upper limb area but the for lower limb
and trunk part
they project more dorsal side of the
strider
and this yellow part receives inputs
from this medius of the network the
visual auditory
recharging area enterocingulate cortex
and this pink area receive more of the
input from
classically we call it limbic system
that is
in the aggregate insular temp
in a insurance cortex project to these
areas
and if we look at even more detail
conduct a more
uh detailed network analyze we
really look at the entire striatum we
can subdivide them
into the about 30 different
functional domains each of these
individual functional domains
they receive their special set
of the cortical inputs
so for example like here that's a again
that is a
uh entire semantic sensory motor area
remember they forms
distinctive sub networks so we can see
how these different cyber networks they
project to the
uh striatum but they the here
interesting things like their projection
to the stratum they form this
upside down the homunculus so basically
it's like a trunk
from trunk cortical areas of uh from
primary somatosensory primary
motor cortex the if they are related to
trunk functions the the terminals in the
uh dorsolateral stratum for the
artificial parts
they are more like a ventral lateral
side of the
striatum so they have some part overlap
some part of a divergency but overall is
remembered in the cortex part of they
have like a
semantic sensory symmetrical motor if
their forms
sub networks that control the trunk or
lower limb they project to mostly
overlap
terminals in the striatum so if their
mouse regions are projected to the
ventral lateral side
so again uh so the for the
visual auditory and the media networks
the muscle is a project to this
dorsal medial region of the stratum but
the
insular part and also in toronto cortex
the project to the ventral lateral side
of strident
and again this one that is really
highly correlated with the cortical
networks if the cortical areas
in the cortex part they highly connect
to each other the project tended to has
like more overlap in the same
same domains in the strident
and here's some really nice relatively
segregated terminals in the stratum
so based on overall this entire cortical
there are terminals used
in the striatum this this is the maximum
uh projections of the axon terminal from
more than 80 different cortical areas
there are terminals in the stratum
based on this pattern we can see this
striatum
clearly this functional related means
for example this dorsal media domain
here receive convergent inputs from the
visual cortex and the insurance cortex
which means
this part of a stratum properly involves
the integration
of the visual special visual spatial
information and this part that is for
trunk this part of our artificial and
this part that is for visceral
motor uh input from the cortex
and this kind of a functional map across
the
entire uh stride and more rust or more
color
but they have the different special ways
for example
and in the relatively more cauter part
of stratum
they have segregations relatively dorsal
part
you got like eye head neck trunk
movements uh all these cortical areas
projected
here but the lymph uh parts the
projector here and
here's more like for our official part
and more really color part of the
stratum is involved
primarily inputs from the visual
auditory inputs
but this part of stratum actually people
knows very little about it
all right after we look at the entire
cortical cortical networks
look at it there is entire cortex
project with the stratum
and next step is we look at how from the
different these functional demands
identity newly identified function
domains of the stratum
project is downstream uh structure that
is globus paradise
and uh substitutional graph and then
from there
how the projected sounds and then go
back to cortex
so the question really is if we see the
cortex
uh topographic projection to the
striatum and the
now we identify all these clear
subdivisions
of the striatum what is their major how
their
these patterns go to the next step the
paradigm and the niagara
so this part of work still not published
um but uh um we already saw very clear
very interesting patterns for example
this is from strident
uh their projection to the uh globus
pandas to show
all these really clearly segregate
demands and this is from the major
divisions
intermediate uh stratum rostral called
stratum this shows its patterns but also
if we see the community
levels the dorsal lateral eventually
lateral dorsal medial ventral
media also sees relative separate
patterns but interestingly is if we go
to really
find demands in the stratum they
also show the clear pattern in the
paradigm
as the globus pallidus these patterns
which means
the cortex inputs to the stratum they're
relatively separating and then they can
also maintain this uh relatively
segregate
uh projection patterns in the paradigm
so accordingly uh i showed these
functional domains and then we can
try to find the correlated demands in
the paradigm
so we divided the pattern into the about
40 different
domains uh this is just like the legos
the piece and each demand they receive
specific inputs from different part of a
stratum
and also we look at how from
the different stratum demand they
project to the
uh substantial niagara
so remember like this individual
striatum domains
they receive a very specific input from
individual areas and but
i showed here that is more like a
several domains in the ventral
medial demands of the striatum to look
at each individual demand they project
to this
uh different part of a uh [ __ ] and then
put it together
we can also see these functional
uh specialized domains in this in the
[ __ ] part and we mapped these
circuitries
also at the individual uh neuron
resolution which means
like here i showed several individual
neurons
to see their axon individual axons they
go to the generated branch
in the panaderm or the terminals in the
niagara
so that is a high resolution inputs
high resolution axons and then
after we look at the niagara
uh so from the striatum to the [ __ ]
and then we look at from individual
[ __ ]
how they project back to the silence
like here i use the
example that is uh for the uh called the
paravascular nucleus pf uh ceramic
nucleus
these guys and receive the same domain
of this pf receive the inputs from
cortex
but also receive the core correlated
domain
from the striatum from the submission
[ __ ] so which means like
if this part of a stratum receive the
input from the
cortex the correlate cortex and we can
find the
how the in the silence part there are
cortical
inputs to this islamic nucleus and
actually
receive the convergence input from the
substitution [ __ ] so in this case you
form this kind of
entire cortical basal ganglia islamic
cortex this kind of a loop
uh just like what i showed here the same
uh islamic domains these they project
back to these cortical areas
in the same cortical areas project these
ceramic nucleus
this one projector stratum but this part
a stratum project is a uh
corresponding demands in the [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] project back to the islamic
nucleus
and then this guy project back to the
cortex
so in this case we can really really see
how this is the entire cortical piece of
ganglia islamic globe
they form this kind of a really
interesting uh
close sub networks and
we also uh mapped uh these
neurons in the niagara what is their
morphology their individual neurons
how their dendrites extend throughout
this niagara part
and also uh how does their dendrites
match with their inputs from the
striatum
so overall so
overall i
don't have time to go to the really
detailed every sub networks
but overall the information here is this
so entire cortex
we have three
major networks large relatively large
networks
for example somatic sensory
motor networks they uh can
they are organized as several parallel
networks control
trunk lower limb upper limb inner mouse
outer mouse these regions and then each
individual sub networks they have
primary motor cortex
primary sensory secondary motor
secondary sensory
uh each one of these sub networks they
heavily connect with each other at
cortex
level and then these guys
in the same subnetworks they generate
convergent inputs to
the stratum the same domain it doesn't
mean they are terminals they are
completely overlap
they still show some some interesting
patterns but they
project the same domain what we need arm
stands
as this stratum individual neuron
resolution
how this individual neuron uh the
information from different cortical
areas they
integrated at the individual neuronal
resolution but that is the
future work um and
you see like a somatic sensory motor
parts they converge
into the different subdomains mostly
it's a
lateral side of the striatum that is
correlated to the human putamen part
but the media uh associative knight
sub networks that is includes
intercinglic cortex ritual splenium area
parietal association area
orbital frontal cortex they project to
the
dorsal medial striatum part and
lateral cortical areas they project to
the
ventral media striatum part but
each individual demands in the stratum
they then send the parallel projections
to the pattern
at the same time they send interesting
convergence
divergence and patterns to the different
part of a
substrate [ __ ] and remember stridom
also has projections to the paladium
kind of them they have projections to
the
uh uh [ __ ] so which means like if we
bring
in our classic concept direct
pathways versus the yin diver indirect
corticospisal ganglia pathways but they
organize different principles
i don't have time to go to the detail
for that
but eventually when we see this niagara
project back to the xylems use the para
vascular nucleus
as examples they also form these
parallel pathways from
here then they project back to the
entire
cortex so this work is not completely
done
yet but i think like down the road in
the next
several years we're going to uh go to
even more details
to see each individually for example
like at the
niagara part individual [ __ ] neurons
how they receive the convergent
input from the striatamine and also from
paradigm
and how this you know another really
cool questions
how these pathways uh individual
pathways
if the paths will get disrupted how's
that one relate to like a classic
uh disease for example parkinson's
huntington's disease
you know because in these different
disease models for example huntington's
the the huntington's they show different
symptoms for example at the beginning
stage people has a problem
patients have a problem for for their
eye movement and then they have a
problem for swallowing
a food that means they have some problem
with artificial
motor part and eventually it's come to
the
really limbs uh problems
and they also have cognition like both
the
huntingtons and parkinson's patients
they have cognitive problems and
cognitive problems actually come before
even multiple
uh problems so i think like if we we
really
mapped all these networks really clearly
and we because we know lots of functions
about the cortex for example
media prefrontal cortex that is involved
lots of
cognitive functions uh and anti-singlet
cortex involved the different functions
from the motor cortex
and then we if we understand how the
individual areas
they go to find uh demands in the
stratum
and this stratum how they affect the
downstream projections paradigm [ __ ]
and to the salons that will really help
us eventually understand
this really much finer um
resolution just in terms of the for the
disease model
so uh i just i don't have time to go to
the
uh really detail but it's like another
really major direction
uh so in my lab also it's one
major direction for uh brain initiative
in the last
several years and also uh the coming
next
five years that is a two characterized
cell types for the entire uh mouse brain
so which means we look at the this is
the one example for the hippocampus
so hubcaps obviously has many different
neurons what we can show here for
example is a green color
neurons that is a neuron project to the
anterior ventral islamic nucleus you
see these neurons really complex
dendritic arbors
and each dandruff has all these
dendritic
spines you know we know this dendritic
spines that is spot to receive the
inputs
uh and it's a pink color neurons that is
a project back to the
ritual splenium areas and all these red
color neurons
that's the neuron project back to the um
reunion nucleus of asylums so
does so that direction really also is we
what we uh we need to characterize
catalog
neural cell types uh as a single neural
resolution
to look at their inputs and also the
single neural output
and this work will be uh really is a
tremendous worker very labor intensive
and but is involved many
many groups in the country
all right so overall i introduced
my program as like we how to generate
this kind of a multi-skill
worrying diagram uh uh use the
cortical visual ganglia islamic this
system as an example and
uh to show how we go from the regional
specific
level uh and go to the subdivisions
and eventually need to go to the
individual resolution
and also i briefly mentioned the
another major direction is to catalog
cell types in the brain
uh so for this connectome project
obviously that is
has been ongoing for in the last 10
years
and people have used different
technologies
try to understand this connectome at a
different resolution
in the neural imaging field obviously we
have lots of
like a human uh macro
mri dti at this resolution
in the mouse world we use this kind of a
classic
tracers use virus tracers to label the
neural pathways
and then in the electron
microscopy resolution that is go to
really
synaptic synaptic resolution
uh so eventually what we really want is
to
integrate this multi-skill resolution
connecting
to help us to really understand how the
brain
organized at the different
levels eventually will be needed at the
single neural resolution
so when i work on this project really
one really good example
uh i want to put here is to show this
kind of a story the blind man with
elephant
you see like the different the little
mans they touch one body of the elephant
and then report okay the elephant this
guy report elephant
just like a wall and this guy report the
elephant just like a rope
um so this kind of a approach really
just like you know
we we scientists we as a scientist many
times
many years so what we're trying to do is
because we use
special technology we focus on different
brain
regions and we really focus on one
region and then we generate
our hypothesis for example if we really
work on part of our brain
you know we collect this information we
generate a hypothesis and then we just
use this hypothesis to demonstrate okay
my hypothesis is
right uh i think the elephant is just
like a wall
you know so so it's it's a scientific
evidence but on the other hand
uh we need have a
global view so hopefully the connection
this project eventually we can integrate
the
information uh from all different
modalities uh uh different uh
the disciplines uh so
and then can give us a big picture what
the
elephant is um so that is uh
really to bring up into this data
science so why the data science
really important really is not only just
regenerate data but eventually
we need to understand this data you know
what that data means
okay um i can stop here for my talk
and so i uh this is my lab
and uh obviously my work is
involved not only just for generated
data but
also involved lots of computational
parts i didn't
uh talk elaborate here but it really
just that is a contribution great
contributions from my lab
over years and especially for uh hurry
she
made a tremendous contribution for the
organized
uh the project to help help the project
really
ongoing and uh nick
bryan involves the major papers here and
in
women that is uh um he is uh our
informatics group leader yanamuya
you developed a lot of great informatics
um
tools and also the rest of the lab uh
did all the great contributions
and also my collaborators in my
different brain initiative
uh project and i really appreciate the
support from brain initiative
and mh okay so i can stop here and
take some questions and thank you very
much for your attention
oh hong wei thank you so much that is
such a tour de force amount of work and
uh just a lot of work by a lot of really
great people too who
many of whom i happen to know personally
and so it's a it's so nice to see it all
come together one of the things which is
always kind of
uh interesting to think about is i as i
understand
uh your choice you chose the to to look
at the c-57 black mouse because it's the
most ubiquitous
laboratory animal in the world and that
understanding the brain of that example
species would be really important for
um for others you know just terms of
its ubiquity their uh the genetic
homogeneity of it
um it was made a really great model but
i'm curious because it has been so
studied and has been so looked at did
you
what is the really the thing that really
got you excited
as the new discovery of looking at the
brain of this particular
animal yeah so we pick up this
mice it's not because one reason is
really just
because it's a practical and um
we study the neural circuitry eventually
to try to understand their function
so for the c57 black that is the most
popular models for the genetics
so there are so many genetic disease
models use this
using mouse and uh molecular
people they they use this one you know
all the genomic
people they they you also use mouse
brain
and also in terms of size in terms of
your circuitry because it's much
smaller it's easier to you look at the
entire mouse brain
i don't have the time talk today but
like a recent years
we started using the light sheet
microscopy
uh do the brain clearing and then to
look at the internal mouse connection
patterns
so the mouse brain is relatively smaller
so give you the
opportunity to map the entire uh
brain rather in comparison with the rat
and
monkey's brain they are much bigger and
then that will be involved even more
uh ones labor and other things really
date size
and also the mouse really the most
important things because we can direct
the core a little bit
use the later on for people you use the
genetic model
so we when we look at the circuitries in
the wide type mice and
we can use this the same circuitry
people can understand in the disease
models
how that happened um that's being said
but recent years for the brain
initiative start to really
think about like i use the monkeys
because
for us ultimate goal is really
understanding human brains
so the primates for example mom side
that is a
really good model to uh
for us the next step after we understand
the mouse
to see the in the user's mouth in your
uh mom's side to look at uh in the
primates
what's the circuitry is common in the
mouse brain and what is the difference
and that mom's side can be as an
intermediate station for us to really
understand the human brain
but obviously eventually we need to see
in the human brain how the connectivity
compared with mouse brain
us many of these circuitries we learn
from
mouse can be applied in the human for
example this is a
cortical striatal projection that i just
showed
my thinking we find the really finer sub
deficiency in the mouse
striatum functional demands the same
thing can be applied directly
in the human brain and obviously still
a lot of work needed to be done for a
human brain and that is that
we're waiting for some new exciting
technologies coming out in the next
several years
do you plan to do any work with um kind
of disease
model mice i mean it sounds like you
alluded to that are there any specific
diseases that
you would want to try to uh to look for
look at the
connectivity of in mouse models yes we
have been trying to look at
the uh this connectivity in the
huntington's disease
uh and also at mice um but
uh to go to the disease model part
and that's also is really uh it's not
the easy task so we need to devote our
time
specifically to work on this model you
know but that is definitely
that is the direction we're going so we
we
at this moment we really towards to
think about it's really the huntington's
and also 80 and probably also
parkinson's this is three major models
that's cool
here's a question from one of our
participants
what about parafasicular projections to
the striatum do they largely overlap
with the inputs from cortical regions
they connect to and could this
redundancy
be a mechanism behind why locomotor
control and many aspects of learning are
preserved in decorticated mice
you have any thoughts on that uh yes so
paraphersical
it turns out that actually it's very
interesting
on very interesting structures
i'm just like so happy at the beginning
stage we didn't in fact it's so
complicated
and so when we look at our uh
projections connections actually it's a
reciprocal connections
paraphrase killer visa cortex we find
the paraphesical nucleus can be
subdivided into this multiple domains
and these multiple demands they are very
highly
topographically arranged for example the
para vascular
uh the lateral part pyrovascular more
dorsal part
that is the more uh heavily reciprocal
connections with the cortex
related to control the trunk part
relatively more
vengeful in as like a intermediate
middle
level that is the for the upper limit
and eventual lateral side
of paravascular nucleus that is for the
controlled artificial part
but like more media site like a dorsal
and a ventral side that is
paraparticular nucleus really heavily
involves the classical
limbic cortical areas for example infant
limbic cortical
areas they you know they release
in the media also lateral
side of paraphysical nucleus uh and we
interestingly we find is when we map
these corticostriatal
[ __ ] pathways and these pathways
from niagara different demands the
project paraphrasicular nucleus
really matched just like emi talk i
mentioned is
the same functional loop actually all
preserved from cortex to striatum to the
[ __ ] then to paraphysical
nucleus then back to the cortex so it's
thinking like we for the paraphysical
letter we identified
six major domains that is a
six parallel sub networks came back to
the cortex
did i answer your question right i i i
think that
is a great answer uh for that question
so thank you i hope that our our
participant was satisfied um one thing
that you mentioned is the the notion of
looking at mapping the cells in the
mouse brain
and i'm thinking of things like
um broad men's regions for example in
the human brain which are so
widely noted um but i also know that uh
broadman did some work in his
cytoarchitectonic corpus um in a number
of other species i believe including the
mouse
i'm curious whether or not you find any
sort of
mappings that would link cyto
architectonics with some of the
connectomics you're seeing
um and that have overlap between these
projection areas and the
the regions that you're identifying does
there seem to be some sort of
cell type pattern as well that
superimposes itself upon this
connectomic pattern
yeah so yeah another project i didn't
talk about
today here that is a recent project
um is a really collaborative project
among more than 16 different
institutes cross-country uh from this
brain initiative cell sense
network and the organizer for the
anatomy part
so in this part we look at the cell
types in the primary motor cortex
so basically so we define is the primary
motor cortex
anatomically and especially we focus on
uh primary motor cortex upper limb area
uh so we look at the different cell
types in this
primary motor cortex they project to the
different cell types
for example layer two three neurons
layer uh
four events we identified the primary
motor cortex actually also has a very
thin layer layer four
uh and the layer five neurons they
project to the different part of brain
so for example let's see uh in the human
you got like a really
big cortical spinal projection neurons
in the primary motor cortex in the mouse
brain actually
yeah that is basically the same cell
types also has this
big neurons project to the spinal cord
and we use the tracers to label these
neurons
injecting to the cervical spinal cord
back labels these big neurons in the
cortex we know these guys where exactly
where they're located
and where they project you so we
basically
identify these neurons
cortical spinal projection neurons use a
different
anatomical uh
tracer method region specifically and
also the use single neuron we can see
single neurons
project to the downstream medulla
different parts and then see their
branch
but at the same time also brain
initiatives sponsored
other groups they look at the individual
neurons what is their molecular
uh profiles you know so what is the
molecular identities
so this information
can be used actually in the other groups
in the brain needs to sponsor groups
already
compare the same cell types
try to look at uh cross difference
between mouse
monkeys and humans what is their
molecular uh
i think molecular profiles whether you
can find the same moleculars or
different
uh and then compare their cell types so
eventually
in the downstroke in sex in the next
several years this information we will
you will get we will get
a really massive amount of data try to
compare the different cell types
across human and mouse brain and also
primary spring
oh this is leads me into my next
question is there's clearly an enormous
amount of data science which is required
to deal with
this massive amount of individual
cellular data how they're all connected
what uh subsystems
um and sub networks exist in these large
data sets
um what do you see as some of the things
that
data science can contribute to and what
do you see as
kind of attributes that data scientists
you know might have
if they're going to come into this field
and help analyze this rich
amount of neural information yeah
so actually the data science that will
become really key
uh for downgrade and for
producing data is only the first step
so over the last several years like my
lab that is a
student's academic labs a relatively
small academic lab
but we already produced huge amount of
connectivity data and we can obviously
we are
trying our best to to write papers try
to understand how
different regions they form these
networks but
still that we still have tons tons data
just in our computer
uh we haven't got time to really analyze
that one and alan institute obviously
that is a
big institute they produce tons tons of
data already
in there they release in their website
but the key
question still is how we can understand
this data
so so that one just really come to the
uh the data science part we need to
develop a more
uh powerful tools um to really
uh to analyzing data to especially
perform the integrative analyze joint
data analyze
so that is a part of this of brain
initiative cell sensor networks
and that's a i'm involved this program
that's a brain initiative sponsored
so for this program they ask
every lab in this program producing the
data
and then we submit this data to
pittsburgh supercomputer center
that is as a data center for the brain
initiative
and brain initiative is going to release
this data make it
available to an entire community
that is the first step makes this data
openly available to the entire community
and then this offers the data available
second
uh approach second step actually
involved all of us our we have the brain
initiative grants
but also actually involved should be
like for the entire
community try to really understand this
in your
circuitry data and a single neural rn
sequence data
and some spatial transcription data how
put this data together i try to
understand
um what this data means especially
uh for understand the new neural cell
types for the cell types that is
uh we define the cell types is a not
only we shouldn't define cell types
based on one criteria based on
their connection or based on their our
single neural r sequence data instead
we should based on their integrative
features for example these cell types
what is their
um first is the anatomy location where
they're located you know they're in the
primary
motor cortex or the primary sensory
cortex
and also uh their connections
their physiology properties what is
their firing patterns
and what is their molecular identities
eventually understand what is their uh
function what's this cell type involved
which behavior
control which behavior what function so
basically when
all of this really require the data
science
to data science to uh that is involved
importantly many different things
include the data visualization
well thank you hong wei i really
appreciate you sharing your
amazing work with us today uh if it is
any
indication of the just a massive amount
of
work that's ahead of us uh especially uh
where data sciences is related
um we're going to have a a lot of work
to do but it's very exciting work
so thank you so much for sharing your uh
your work with us today
i want to thank everybody who's part of
our uh biomedical data science
innovation lab program and i want to
thank everybody out on youtube for uh
taking part uh
in our activity today and throughout
this year
um we're gonna be taking a bit of a
break over the holidays so we want to
wish you a very happy holidays
and just let you know that we'll be
beginning again on january 8th
again 9 a.m pacific and 12 p.m eastern
with our biomedical data science seminar
series and so with that thank you again
hong wei
thank you again everybody have a happy
holidays and a safe new year
and we'll see you on january 8th thank
you again
thank you very much jack thanks to
everyone